figaro live bonjour on est en direct ce
lundi matin pour continuer de suivre ce
qui se passe en ukraine je suis avec
alexis fait chaque bonjour alexis lui
vincent adjoint paul actu du figaro on
va décrypter grâce aux cartes tout ce
qui se passe en ce moment en ukraine
tout ce qui s'est passé ce week-end
beaucoup d'actualité bien évidemment
tout au long de l'année bien sûr vous
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions que
ce soit sur le chat du figaro ou sur
celui de youtube et on voit là on va
essayer d'y répondre au mieux possible
on va commencer par les cartes donc dont
vous parlez la carte principale est
celle là celle ci donc là est la carte
des différentes avancées alexis comment
évolue la situation générale en ukraine
alors la situation générale c'est un peu
ce qu'on aurait dit déjà la première
fois qu'on avait fait un avis il ya
trois jours celle qui a une il ya une
avancée russe ça c'est indubitable
néanmoins ya pas de grandes villes qui
ont été et qui ont été prises on va en
reparler
mais en revanche ce qui est aussi très
clair c'est que les forces du craignait
ne se sont pas effondrés donc ça c'est
vraiment la situation générale sur le
terrain et après il y avait deux autres
moments importants ce week-end c'était
la russie qu'a annoncé qu'elle mettait
en état d' alerte spécial ses forces
nucléaires stratégiques
on ne reparlera et puis aussi le
lancement parallèle de négociations qui
ont lieu je sais pas si vous voyez dans
la dans la carte la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
près de la ville de gomez voilà qui
honore un an de cartes effectivement on
va reparler de tout ça effectivement
le la principale information c'est qu'on
s'attendait à ce que la russie et kras
rapidement le les forces ukrainienne
finalement ça n'a pas été le cas
absolument ça c'est une
enfin une nouvelle importante comme quoi
il ya toujours dans la guerre des aléas
du hasard est ce que clausewitz appelait
le brouillard de la guerre donc rien
n'est joué à l'as vence
après je voudrais quand même rappeler
que le rapport de forces est quand même
en faveur de la russie mais il ya une
résistance incroyable une résidence
ukrainienne cas c'est assez incroyable
portée par la volonté par
par le parle pas par le courant le plus
craignant est aussi parle
là la position de leurs de son président
céline stick et 20 ans apparue comme un
comme un chef de guerre au sens noble du
terme 5 arrive à maintenir le le moral
des troupes et de la population derrière
lui effectivement et quilter qui tient
tête en plus à
bannir tout in il a multiplié ses
séjours les apparitions télévisées ne se
cache pas absolument il ya quelque chose
qui est intéressant il a pris un peu
plus tina son jeu 5 depuis le début vous
admire poutine minimise
l'intervention ça qui l'a pas dit que
c'était une invasion ou une bière etc
donc il n'a pas du tout l'ascendant sur
la question de la de la communication la
narration de cette guerre alors qu'au
contraire kiev en tout cas semble avoir
gagné une guerre c'est la guerre de la
communication et ce qu'ils ont entendu
reggae avec quelque chose de très
important alors d une question de nice
texte qui est assez précise je situe
vous pour pouvoir y répondre quel est le
volume des forces engagées à kiev en
termes de volume on sait qu'il ya une
vraie guerre de l'information qui jouait
ce qu'on peut vraiment savoir le nombre
de forces engagées oui alors il faut
vraiment faire très attention avec tous
les chiffres les bilans qui sont qui
sont annoncés que ce soit par cafu par
moscou je répondais manière plus
générale on sait que depuis des mois il
y avait environ
cent cinquante mille hommes cent
cinquante mille soldats russes qui
étaient déployés
aux frontières de l'ukraine hélas les
dernières estimations c'est que entre la
moitié et les deux tiers
de ces hommes ont été déployés dans
l'ensemble
de l'ukraine autrement dit
on est entre 50 et 100 mille hommes
voilà ce qui est déjà important mais ça
ne l'est pas il faut quand même rappeler
que l'ukraine est un pays qui est plus
grand que la france en superficie et que
la population est de 40 millions
d'habitants
c'est quand même c'est très gros en a
ici est beaucoup plus grand en
superficie mais la population c'est ses
140 millions donc scellé on est dans un
rapport de 1 3 à 4 en terme de
population donc voilà juste en terme
d'ordre de grandeur passée
impressionnant effectivement auprès des
différents fonds qui évoluent dans cette
guerre le premier c'est celui du nord le
fraudeur avec la frontière biélorusse
comment les forces russes ont progressé
sur celui-là on sait que c'est celui qui
est le plus proche de grève alors c'est
celui qui est le plus proche de kiev et
donc c'est le plus stratégique il ya un
élément géographique est important
l'ukraine est traversé de nord du nord a
loué au sud par un grand fleuve qui
s'appelle le dniepr est donc en fait qui
a fait le long d'une ligne est prêt à
150 km au sud de la frontière biélorusse
est en fait ce qu'on voit c'est bien sûr
la sur la carte j'espère qu'on le voit
c'est que depuis le début de l'offensive
jeudi dernier il ya en fait trois 3 perd
ses différentes vers vers kiev l'une
vraiment au nord quasiment nord-ouest
qui est sur la rive droite du nieppe on
va montrer la carte de kiev oui pour
mieux comprendre à qui est pour le coup
est vraiment résout mais par sur kiev
mais on comprend si vous voulez on voit
le niais promis mieux globalement il ya
une
une offensive par par le nord ouest et
deux autres enfants cible on voit pas
parce qu'elles se réunion mais mais qui
viennent du nord-est et de l'est et en
fait ce qui est important de comprendre
c'est que la bataille de kiev
a commencé mais faut faire attention
c'est à dire que les ya eu des combats
dans kiev c'était notamment le cas
samedi
avenue de la victoire qui est des
grandes artères de kiev à l ouest mais
pour l'instant c'est ce qu'on appelle
des troupes avancent et russe notamment
des forces spéciales les troupes
aéroportées
et donc ça veut pas dire que toute
l'armée russe est arrivé à kiev c'est en
tout cas c'était la situation jusqu'à
samedi soir et ce qui est important de
noter c'est que
veut dire dans la partir de samedi soir
jusqu'à dimanche les russes ont très
clairement pour le coup contrôler la
zone au nord ouest de kiev est donc là
ça leur permet aux diables d'envoyer des
renforts en assurer la logistique etc et
c'est très difficile de savoir
exactement où sont les lignes de front
en tout cas le maire de kiev ce matin a
déclaré que la que la ville était
encerclée est ce que c'est exactement le
cas quand on regarde les dernières
cartes les données publiques qu'on n'a
pas l'impression que tout y est ou qui a
fait et est encerclé n'est en tout cas
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il ya une
pression russe qui se rapproche de plus
en plus et qu'effectivement on a parlé
de vue du front du nord et du front de
l'est effectivement 2 qui arrive aussi
alors ce n'est pas cette carte là c'est
encore au dessus
donc le front de l'est qui était le
front a priori le plus facile pour pour
le numérique et des russes alors le plus
facile non pas vraiment parce que les
c'est aussi là que les ukrainiens
avaient mis les défilés le plus de
défense la meilleure défense donc c'est
un front qui était très difficile il ya
des combats extrêmement intense autour
de kharkiv donc on voit sur le front de
l'est un peu un peu au nord kharkiv
c'est la deuxième ville du pays donc
c'est évidemment un objectif très
important après ce que je voudrais dire
sur la stratégie russe c'est visible ont
ils encerclent les villes
leur stratégie principale ne sont pas
être la presse des villes mais plutôt il
essaye de les contourner pour contrôler
les grands axes routiers parce que
encore une fois ce que j'ai dit là à
l'instant c'est que l'objectif principal
c'est qu'ils aient fait donc on voit
très bien ils ont contourné soumis alors
ils sont un peu entré dedans sont
ressortis etc mais ils n'ont pas tenu la
ville et même quand on voit le front de
l'est ce qui va vers kiev
ils ont contourné kono top qu'est la
ville qui à un moment il ya des taches
blanches qui est non contrôlés dans la
pas par la russie dans la dans la zone
rouge bien ça c'est la grande ville de
cotonou qui sont passées autour des
villes et ce qui pose un certain nombre
de difficultés c'est un front qui
s'élargit avec des poches qui sont pas
tenus par par la russie et donc
notamment pour la logistique
sané ça n'est pas évident mais ça on ne
reparlera en parler vraiment de tout
comment ça se passe sur le sur le
terrain il ya un troisième français
celui du sud le celui qui vient de la
crimée on a une carte spéciale pour
celui là attendez on va la retrouver
elle est ici les les russes qui avaient
progressé très facilement au début sur
ce front oui alors absolument donc donc
les l'invasion russe par de crime elle
rappelle que la crimée avaient été
annexées par la russie en 2014 après la
révolution du maidan donc elle fait
partie maintenant intégrante de la
fédération de russie en tout cas selon
le droit russe part reconnu par la
communauté internationale et donc ce
qu'on voit là c'est facilement c'est les
deux objectifs principaux de la russie
c'est donc toujours depuis le sud mais
vers l'est c'est de prendre les bords de
la mer d'azov keane mer fermée qui de
facto est déjà contrôlée par
par la russie mais ça permet de créer un
corridor terrestre pour accéder depuis
le territoire russe jusqu'à créer mais
parce que si vous descendez un tout
petit peu en crimée qu'on voit mieux la
craie mais voilà en fait il n'y a pas de
passage terrestre entre la crimée et
krasnodar à la lassitude c'est une mer
fermée mais à cannes un des trois qui
venait de détroit de kertch est alors
certes il ya un pont coq a été construit
très vite par les russes mais c'est
quand même pas très commode et c'est
notamment pas très commode pour l'eau
parce que l'eau de crime et vient
d'ukraine
donc ça c'est un objectif stratégique
probable de la russie c'est d'établir un
corridor terrestre vers les régions
séparatistes du dombass et de ce point
de vue là les russes ont bien avancé je
disais qu'il n'avait pas pris de ville
ils ont visiblement pris une ville
qu'est berne y en a c'est une petite
ville de faire une petite ville une
moyenne de cent mille habitants et qui
par ailleurs un petit port ils ont
supprimé litho paul convoi juste avant
et donc là il avance vers marioupol
marioupol c'est symbolique cela
permettrait vraiment la réunion ii du
dombass et du combat séparatistes et des
forces qui viennent de l'ouest là juste
un point ils n'ont qui n'ont pas pris
marioupol il semblerait que d'une
certaine manière marioupol est quasi
encerclé ou en cours d'encerclement ça
ça rappelle vraiment là la méthode russe
qui avait été adoptée déjà en 2014 face
à l'arménie chrétienne il aime bien
créer des des poches on appelle cela des
chaudrons les cautèles nom en russe
cécile vieille stratégie
militaire soviétique avait été vue
notamment pour la seconde guerre
mondiale et là on peut penser que l'une
des une fin la stratégie vraiment
militaire de la russie s'est créé comme
ça des zones d'encerclement
d'encerclement certain nombre d'endroits
si on remonte tout en haut à la carte
principale on peut tout à fait imaginer
mais encore une fois c'est vraiment
conditionnel que face au front de l'est
qui résiste notamment un quart kharkiv
est bien en passant par le nord par le
sud etc la russie pourrait réussir à
coincer les forces du crânienne dans un
certain nombre de poches qui pourraient
se constituer dans l'est du pays est ce
que justement un ses violons marie-paule
va se retrouver en état de siège oui
c'était l'idée c'est ça l'idée notamment
parce que marioupol est assez bien
protégé à marioupol notamment si j'ai
bien compris il ya bataillon azoff le
bataillon azoff c'était un bataillon de
volontaires qui avaient émergé en 2014
qui est extrêmement motivé
très clairement c'est un bataillon
d'extrême droite on sait qu'à une
minorité des nationalistes ukrainiens
qui sont vraiment vraiment d'extrême
droite
si j'ai bien compris ils sont
notamment à marioupol et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en face il
semblerait aussi
qu'il y ait des combattants tchétchènes
du côté du côté russe on sait qu'il y en
a aussi prédit kiev
donc la tchétchénie de kadyrov et qui
fait partie visuelle de la russie statut
un peu
autonomes et les tchétchènes alors
pourquoi les envoyer déjà ils ont sont
très aguerris ils font année en syrie et
notamment series ont fait la
contre-insurrection du combat urbain
donc malheureusement dans une bière
comme ça ça peut être entre guillemets
utile pour la russie et l'autre avantage
c'est qu'on sait que pour les russes se
battre contre des ukrainiens c'est
affreux céder ses frères ses des frères
il ya une grande partie de la
population-- chronique à la famille en
russie et inversement et donc d'envoyer
des tchétchènes entre guillemets ils ont
peur osons peut-être un peu moins de
deux difficultés avec à se battre tu
parles de cette stratégie tout à l'heure
de passer à côté des villes est ce qu'on
peut imager on peut s'imaginer justement
que ces deux fronts celui du sud et
celui de l'est se rejoignent finalement
au dessus de marie-paule pour l'instant
où oui c'est tout à fait une hypothèse
je pense que pour l'instant il faut pas
trop s'avancer mais oui c'est une
hypothèse toujours dans l'idée de créer
des pôles d'encerclement pour affaiblir
l'armée ukrainienne par ailleurs à
propos d'un crime et donc qu'elle à
l'offensive qui passe vers l'est pour
contrôler mer d'azov et créer ce que
reader mais il ya aussi le faon cif qui
passe
le nom reste injuste sur la wii par donc
oui c'est certain regard du site
absolument bien mieux on va les voir en
ce moment ici on voit laquelle offensif
qui part vers l'ouest et notamment on
revoit de nouveau le lièvre est à
l'embouchure d'une lumière brille à
cette ville qui s'appelle carson alors
on a pour l'instant dans les territoires
contrôlés par la russie on n'est pas
allé au delà du dniepr faut quand même
savoir qu'il ya des combats
très violents qui se passe depuis
plusieurs jours au delà d'une ligne
après les forces armées russes sont
arrivés jusqu'à nikolaïev la situation
est confuse sur le terrain ce qui est
très clair c'est que les russes n'ont
pas consolidé leur emprise mais il ya
des combats très violents à kars enfin
devant personne et même à l'intérieur un
peu de personnes et aux portes de de
nicolay if donc ce qui est très clair
c'est que les russes avancent maintenant
est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à tenir
donc là c'est vraiment l'accès à la mer
noire de l'ukraine et donc l'accès à la
mer tout court sert qu'ensuite si les
russes parvenait à aller au-delà jusqu'à
au dessin qui est la troisième ville
d'ukraine et qui est le plus grand port
ukrainien et qui en plus une ville
chargée d'histoire c'est une ville très
multiculturelle c'est un peu là souvent
comparé à marseille
et est par ailleurs cinéville aussi
historiquement très importante pour les
russes a été fondée en 1994 par
l'impératrice catherine ii donc donc
voilà il ya aussi ce front de l'ouest
qui se dégage aujourd'hui très nettement
et comme lié c'est quand même très
importante pour les propos les rues
d'arriver à couper finalement l'accès à
la mer pour les pour les ukrainiens
alors on peut l'imaginer mais encore une
fois ça dépend des objectifs
stratégiques de la russie
et ça c'est encore la grande un peu flou
ce qui est très clair c'est qu'ils
veulent prendre la certitude ils veulent
prendre kiev parce que kiev ça leur
permettrait
de faire tomber le gouvernement ça c'est
visiblement l'objectif stratégique de
niro en devenir tout est effectivement
pour réussir à peut-être arriver à
mettre en place un gouvernement plus pro
russe un gouvernement qu'il est qu'il
est qui lui hier est plus on a bien
l'impression que c'était son objectif de
base est ce que on sait ce que veulent
les russes en plus de ça in fine et il
ya plusieurs scénarios qui sont qui sont
envisageables
il ya un scénario qu'il serait gagnée
militairement et ensuite il se retire
après avoir obtenu
du gouvernement ukrainien des garanties
ont fait que les russes sont des
demandes de neutralisation diplomatique
de l'ukraine
clairement aujourd'hui c'est pas un des
scénarios qui paraît le plus probable
il ya un autre scénario qui consisterait
à établir
en ukraine un gouvernement fantoche
pro-russe
sur l'intégralité du territoire
ukrainien
là ça va poser un énorme problème pour
la réussite de les numéros utiles si il
arrive à la deuxième place à m même
avant de le mettre en place et de le
tenir il faut il faut il faut contrôler
l'intégralité l'ukraine c'est encore
loin d'être fait peut-être qu'on pourra
en reparler après mais militairement les
rats les choses ne sont pas que comme on
pouvait l'imaginer à l'origine donc il
ya cette hypothèse et d'un gouvernement
pro russe qu'il tiendrait de manière
autoritaire le pays mais là c'est à dire
occuper un pays de 600 mille kilomètres
carrés de 40 millions d'habitants avec
une population qu'ils dans son ensemble
n'a aucune envie d'être sous là sous la
coupe de dictatures enfin de d'un régime
militaire qui tiendrait le pays
ça serait extrêmement coûteux pour
vladimir poutine et puis pour très
longtemps je veux dire mettre un
gouvernement pro russe mais mais
pourquoi faire dans quelle direction
dans quel visée politique et puis à une
option maximaliste qui consisterait à
annexer purement et simplement
l'ukraine
bon déjà par rapport au droit
international fois toute manière il sait
3,19 internationale n'est plus respectée
depuis très longtemps mais ça serait
évidemment très radicale et surtout se
pose exactement le même problème c'est
comment vladimir poutine peut-il tenir
durablement
l'ukraine il ya des scénarios
intermédiaires qu'on peut imaginer avec
une sorte de partition du lucre année là
on peut tout imaginer mais globalement
on pourrait imaginer que
vladimir poutine conserve une sorte d'
état fantoche pro-russe dans l'est de
l'ukraine voilà en récupérant ces
fameuses région qui sont plutôt
russophone oui mais attention elles sont
russophones mais pas dire qu'elles ont
envie des normes voilà
mais c'est un scénario intermédiaire
qu'on pourrait imaginer
puis il entre guillemets il lâcherait
l'ouest de l'ukraine et si la fée
l'ouest de l'ukraine est ce que ça
voudrait dire
que l'ouest de l'ukraine rentrerait non
dans l'otan on voit pas très bien en
somme ce que ce que vladimir poutine
peut gagner je j'ai lu notamment
jean baptiste jean jacques villemaire
directeur de l'irsn
importants think tank français
qui a écrit un article dans legrand
continue en disant que lanières poutine
avait déjà perdu la guerre ce qui peut
paraître paradoxal puisque sur le
terrain il semble malgré tout la gagner
mais c'est au sens où d'une certaine
manière peut-être que vladimir poutine a
déjà perdu l'ukraine nous l'avait déjà
dit
en 2014 en dix ans la corde le lien
peut-il a gagné la crimée c'est clair
mais ça a un prix c'est qui perd le
reste de l'ukraine en créant un
sentiment national ukrainien en le
renforçant en poussant les ukrainiens
vers l'ouest à travers l'union
européenne et vers le temps
là on peut se reposer la même question
mais entre les deux c'est évidemment la
guerre et des souffrances ils sont
absolument terribles peut-être donc on
peut revenir sur les combats parce que
la ja il ya vraiment une incertitude
enfin il n'est pas une certitude un
étonnement certains observateurs
s'attendaient vraiment une sorte de
blitzkrieg et disait pouvoir mais ils
craignaient ne va pas pouvoir tenir une
invasion russe et en deux trois jours on
en parlait dès jeudi qui elle va t'elle
tombé en 24 heures dans l'art est de
constater qu'au bout de trois jours elle
était inquiète fne nenê n'est pas n'est
pas tomber encore une fois les encours
d'encerclement
ça a étonné beaucoup de gens en fait il
ya une grande modernisation des forces
armées russes qui a commencé à la fin
des années 2000 est donc là on
s'attendait
déjà une ce qu'il envoie dès le départ
énormément de troupes et qu'ils soient
très très offensif notamment avec un
usage massif de l'artillerie de
l'aviation et puis par ailleurs qui met
en avant comme c'était le cas par
exemple en syrie les matériels russes
les plus modernes or ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que ça n'a pas été le cas
alors l'usagé de l'artillerie a été déjà
très puissant et ça fait déjà énormément
de dégâts et de morts
néanmoins entre guillemets on pouvait
s'attendre à pire c'est à dire qu'il ya
eu selon beaucoup d'observateurs encore
une fois
occidentaux
une sorte de retenue russe dans l' usage
de l'artillerie et de l'aviation et donc
du coup ça donne quelque chose d'assez
étonnant c'est qu'on voit des colonnes
de blindés
et d'infanterie russe qui avancent
vers les ukrainiens mais parfois sans
couverture aérienne sans moyens de
reconnaissance et même sans avoir le
contrôle du ciel on a vu par exemple des
des drones turc
tb deux qu'on frappait des convois des
convois russes qui étaient complètement
à l'écart et a vu la menace alors qu'on
sait très bien depuis la guerre de syrie
que ces drones turc pour les russes sont
une menace et ça ça n'a pas semblé
aucune leçon et titre visiblement n'a
été tirée de de cela et par ailleurs on
voit que les armes occidentales qui ont
été fournies à kiev notamment les
missiles antichars portative javeline et
missiles anti-aériens stinger est bien
moins en effet claire sur le terrain
alors après il faut se méfier de toutes
les vidéos les images qui circulent sur
les réseaux sociaux parce que ça rende
dont la propre propagande de guerre et
encore une fois on wagons de gaz naturel
des deux côtés mais donc faut se méfier
d'un effet loupe mais en tout cas ce qui
est très clair c'est qu'il ya un nombre
de blindés russes qui a été perdue qui
est très élevée je donnerai pas de
chiffres donnés les chiffres ukraino
russe servent à rien il y en a beaucoup
et parier encore une fois les les russes
n'ont pas envoyé leurs blindés leur char
les plus les plus modernes contrairement
à ce qui avait été le cas en
syrie donc là c'est assez
assez étonnant ce qu'on observe depuis
hier je vais conclure là dessus sur
cette partie là c'est qu'il semblerait
que les russes aient changé leur braquet
et justement
augmentent leurs tirs d'artillerie et on
a vu notamment ça se voit avec
l'aviation ils ont envoyé des chasseurs
bombardiers très récent des sukhoï 34
des sukhoï 35 qui jusqu'à présent
n'avait pas été engagé
donc ça ça semble vouloir dire que la
russie va va devoir
bon enfin décidé de mettre là
le paquet pour pour enfoncer les troupes
polonaises qui pour le coup pour le pour
l'instant n'a pas été le cas est ce
qu'on peut se dire qu'au départ vladimir
poutine a fait preuve de deux d'arrogant
suffisance source disant ça va ça va se
passer je vais réussir à aller très vite
et finalement ça paye est le cas je
pense qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire
parce qu'on ne sait pas exactement
quelles étaient les motivations
de devenir poutine pourquoi ne pas avoir
fait part à utiliser de autant aussi peu
pourquoi avoir utilisé aussi peu
l'aviation
c'est étonnant de fait aujourd'hui il ya
encore visiblement des défenses
anti-aériennes ukrainienne qui
fonctionne sur le sol ukrainien
donc oui visiblement il ya une surprise
les russes ne s'y attendait pas il ya un
autre point on avait beaucoup mis en
avant les groupements tactiques russes
l'idée c'était d'avoir des forces un peu
s'il ne s'est pas simplement des groupes
d'infanterie d'un côté des groupes de
blindés de l'ordre etc et c'était 2
envoyé des petits groupes comme ça très
modulaire très autonome
et elle est là ça ressemble pas du tout
à ça c'est être con voix de l'infanterie
qui est tout seul de l'artillerie qui
est pas là pour couvrir et des blindés
des chars qui eux-mêmes avance tout seul
avec les flux logistiques ça c'est un
point très important qui ne suivent pas
derrière donc oui visiblement du côté du
kremlin doivent pas être très content
alors des questions de joe causes qui me
demande si les russes veulent se venger
des armes fournies à l'ukraine par
l'otan peut-on envisager une implication
des alliés russes à cette guerre
pour les débuts des piloris parce qu'il
n'y a pas énormément dans l'allier on
pourrait on pourrait penser à la chine
mais la chine était et est et non le
ferait à l'avenir notamment impossible
et la chine
est d'ailleurs relativement en retrait
c'est à dire que les
peut-être que ça lance al'avantage
stratégiquement un très long terme parce
que voilà mais mais en revanche a aucune
envie de rentrer dans le profit c'est
une certitude absolue et en revanche nul
entre le déploiement de deux trous
biélorusse on peut pas l'exclure
c'est pas impossible et justement il y
conduit l'otan qui avait un référendum
c'était le 27 février pas très contents
du tout
cas validé le changement de constitution
de la biélorussie et qui a abandonné son
statut de neutralité diplomatique qui
datait de 1994 et a par ailleurs
abandonné son statut de pays
dénucléarisé donc ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer en cas de montée aux extrêmes
et de
d'escaladé c'est le déploiement de
d'armements nucléaires russes en
biélorussie et justement c'était la
question d'une occasion de djoko est ce
qu'il veut est ce qu'on peut envisager
au final une guerre nucléaire pour dell
annonce hier de deux l'admirent poutine
qui parlait alors je n'ai plus le terme
exact
de
2,2 qui mettait en place un alerte
nucléaire est ce qu'il faut craindre une
guerre nucléaire est ce que c'est
possible ça paraît pas par définition
dans le cadre de la dissuasion faut
toujours le 40 parce que si on ne craint
pas ça fonctionne plus
néanmoins pas le plus probable c'est
quand même que vladimir poutine l'a
utilisent
la question du nucléaire
s'en servent dans un but politique pour
pour peser pour dissuader les
occidentaux
d'intervenir d'une manière ou d'une
autre et pour montrer son mécontentement
et pour faire monter le prix des
enchères après est ce que tous les
spécialistes ont reconnu c'est que par
définition on peut jamais complètement
exclure le pire quelque chose
d'improbable peut arriver mais il ya
plein de
haut niveau avant des regards et ça
serait absolument terrifiant mais
imaginez nos choix tactiques d'une arme
nucléaire en ukraine et déjà pourrait
faire des millions de mains
c'est pas la même chose utiliser les
forces stratégiques dans le cadre de la
dissuasion nucléaire ou là on peut raser
des pays
effectivement
il ya des négociations qui sont qui sont
qui sont en cours qui vont avoir lieu tu
embarques tout à l'heure à côté de la
ville de gomel c'est ça oui absolument à
la frontière entre l'ukraine le oui ça
l'ukraine et la biélorussie juste à côté
de tchernobyl voilà
donc il ya c'est pas au niveau
présidentiel c'est au niveau ministériel
il ya le ministre de la défense
ukrainienne d'un côté et un ancien
ministre de la culture
de l'autre côté côté russe est aussi un
envoyé spécial de de poutine
on va voir ce que ça va donner franche
franchement c'est
possible visage et et ça revient par
ailleurs à poser les questions
qu'on attendait tout à l'heure qu'est ce
que veulent à la russie et
et ça ça dépend aussi de la situation
militaire sur le terrain donc voilà
beaucoup de beaucoup d'inconnues
beaucoup d'incertitudes n'hésitez pas à
poser vos dernières questions on va
terminer cela n'est donc pas très très
longtemps je voulais fausse identité
questions sur la sur le bilan de cette
guerre le bilan civil l'onu a parlé de
100 civils tués en disant que les
chiffres pour être bien plus gros enfin
bien plus important en tout cas est ce
que ces bilans on peut s'y fier ou pas
du tout je pense que le nu 1 l'a bien
dit c'est le cas
il ya 100 civils qui sont hors cessions
mais mais les chiffres par définition
sont très difficiles à obtenir ce qui
est certain c'est que c'est une guerre
de de haute intensité
sur le sol européen et ça depuis les
guerres en ex-yougoslavie
ça n'était pas arrivé depuis très
longtemps je rappelle que manière de
métis mais les gains de textes luis la
vie à effet beaucoup plus de 100
millimes hors jeu pas les chiffres
exacts et par ailleurs je crois que
c'est l'onu qui a estimé qu'ils
pourraient lier pour y avoir de 5 à 7
milles jusqu'à 7 millions de déplacés
à cause du conflit une ukraine
c'est aussi un point très important à
prendre en compte on sait qu'aujourd'hui
a pour l'instant
d'après les dernières estimations je
crois un peu moins de quatre cent mille
réfugiés qui sont déjà allés en majorité
en pologne aussi un peu en slovaquie en
hongrie en moldavie qui sont pas les
pays frontaliers forcément
et ya aucune raison que ça ne continue
pas ça va dépendre de la situation
militaire de la réaction de de poutine
encore une fois pour résumer la
situation sur le plan militaire
une victoire de vladimir poutine est
toujours
probable mais la question c'est à quel
prix à quel prix pour les ukrainiens et
à quel prix pour les russes
on sait que le soutien russe à la guerre
en ukraine
n'est pas forcément énorme mais c'est un
peu le 1e femis voir une victoire
donc et les sanctions vont rien arranger
ça c'est économique contre la contre la
russie
donc voilà une victoire militaire mais à
quel prix est par ailleurs question
politique c'est est ce que vladimir
politiquement historiquement n'a pas
déjà perdu l'ukraine oui effectivement
alors c'était un c'est un article dont
tu parlais de jean-baptiste jeangène
vilmer jauge en profite parce qu'on a vu
fondre leurs commentaires dans la rade
qui me disaient que c'étaient des propos
mais c'est les propos de 2,2 de cette
personne qui veut que je cite je vois la
queue qu'alexia visite est bien
évidemment merci à tous en tout cas
d'avoir suivi ce savoir suivi ce direct
il n'y a plus d'autres questions nous
allons nous arrêter là beaucoup
d'informations à suivre un conseil de
défense qui ce qui se passe en ce moment
à l'elysée jean castex qui va recevoir
les différents candidats à la
présidentielle à partir de 15 heures et
forcément beaucoup de déclarations qui
devraient tomber dans la journée on
s'attend encore une journée très chargée
en un ultime le mans et on met les
cartes à jour régulières et on met les
carthage ont bien évidemment merci
encore alexis d'avoir été présents ce
matin merci au service infographie pour
son énorme travail justement sur la sur
la cartographie et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro live